quick push-up routine that will increase
your pushing power body control and
general functional performance and it
only takes ten minutes this one's quite
unlike most circuits or programs you may
have used before because it consists
entirely of one move the push-up but to
increase the challenge and to keep
things interesting will be varying the
cadence the angles and the types of
contraction use most programs are
entirely focused on the fast repetitions
using submaximal weights you pump out a
few reps and sets then you head on to
the next movement you don't truly master
any one of these movements what happens
we need to be stronger what happens when
you need to exert strength for an
extended period and have you really
mastered the movement if you can't also
perform it slowly this is what I mean
when I say dynamic strength the ability
to be explosive when you need to be
force to be slow and controlled or to
churn out lots of reps to be able to
adapt to the demands of any situation
the aim here therefore is to master the
push-up by targeting every type of
muscle fiber and every facet of strength
in that range of motion it goes like
this overcoming isometric push-ups or
floor hugs for three times six seconds
explosive clapping push-ups so technical
failure one-handed push-ups to failure
push-ups to failure quasi isometric
push-ups for thirty Seconds typically
you'll rest for thirty seconds between
each set and repeat the circuit for a
total three to five rounds the rest
between rounds is also only thirty
seconds the short rest time ensures that
you're going into each set already
fatigued which will force the body to
switch its muscle fiber recruitment in
other words because you've used all of
the slow twitch fiber your body has no
choice but to recruit faster twitch
muscle fiber even for those slower
movements try it and suffer
alternatively you can perform this
pushup routine as a single drop set so
that you move on to the next step
immediately after finishing the last one
in this case you should stop each
exercise slightly before failure in
order to ensure you are still able to
perform this method is less effective
for building the complete push-up
strength but I'll allow you to get a
quick and intense workout that can also
be tacked onto a full body routine or
push day so now we're going to break
down each movement as mentioned the aim
of the routine is to take a single
movement and tackle it in every way this
is how that works so the overcoming
isometric movement is one that involves
pushing or pulling against an immovable
force this is equivalent to trying to
lift a barbell that's too heavy for you
meaning that you can exert
maximum effort and maximum neural drive
in other words the brain tries to
recruit every last muscle fiber it can
which can improve the muscle fiber
recruitment overtime and thus increased
maximum strength in other words you can
tap into more of the strength that's
already there this may also help you to
access more explosive force in the next
set thanks to the post activation
principle normally overcoming isometrics
involve using some kind of external tool
but with this move which i've kind of
invented we're going to use the floor to
create a bodyweight overcoming isometric
to do this you widen your arms so that
they are too wide to push you up then
you're going to try and push up
nonetheless straining against the ground
and not going anywhere it should look
like you're trying to PEC fly or to hug
the floor or as I prefer to crush the
earth you're going to hold each one of
these for six seconds with a maximal
effort then release and rest for 10
seconds and then repeat for the next
part of this push-up routine you'll be
performing explosive push-ups
showboating and clapping optional this
is plyometric training which again
activates as many fast twitch muscle
fibers as possible for a display of
plyometric explosive strength it's all
help you to improve your rate of force
development meaning that you can access
more strength more quickly next we're
moving on to one-handed push-ups
this movement is unilateral so it
isolates a single PEC tricep and
shoulder this allows you to increase the
load such that you are now likely
working with an equivalent of more
weight you're also going to be bracing
your entire body more with your obliques
to combat the rotational force this
means you're using slightly different
intramuscular coordination following the
clapping push-ups in the overcoming
isometrics you may already be facing
some fatigue
[Music]
next we're gonna be doing regular
push-ups for many of us it's relatively
easy to perform huge numbers of push-ups
normally this should now be harder
following what has immediately preceded
this move this is why we're keeping
those rest periods very short
you'll still likely be able to do a lot
of push-ups though when you combine this
with everything you've already done this
means you're now working at work
capacity and your muscle endurance
you're using more slow-twitch muscle
fiber which will help to build more work
capacity it'll increase blood flow to
the area encouraging hypertrophy to
final you're going to end this push-up
routine by performing a quasi isometric
pushup this means you'll be slowing the
movement all the way down taking 15
seconds on the way down and 15 seconds
on the way back up if you're confident
you can increase this to 30 seconds each
way the quasi isometric pushup of course
requires a great amount of slow twitch
muscle fiber as well as a huge amount of
muscle control because there's no
acceleration you won't be able to rely
on momentum to jump past sticking points
in the movement what's more is that
you'll build great for prior ception and
body awareness as you consciously move
for each point make sure you're using
perfect technique so your back is in
that hollow body position and you're
coming all the way down to the ground
this will make the movement much more
efficient in future and this is
especially true if you use a passive
isometric on the way down that means
you're using only the necessary muscle
to go through the movement and not
contracting anything excessive or extra
on top of that now the best part is that
when you start round two and thirty
Seconds the fact that your slow twitch
muscle fiber has been exhausted means
that you'll be forced to rely on a great
proportion of fast twitch muscle fiber
emulating a heavier weight
so many training routines focus on
hitting the same muscle groups with
slightly different exercises here the
exercise is largely the same but what
varies is the speed and the intent that
you train it with you'll find that even
though you're exhausted from maxing out
your regular push-ups you're still
capable of performing slow quasi
isometric reps why because these use the
muscles and the nervous system in
entirely different ways and we can
perform normally explosively
unilaterally and with extreme control
and precision you'll be able to say that
you have mastered that movement and it
makes for one hell of a workout that
creates a lot of pump and that should
trigger hypertrophy no matter what kind
of training you respond bestie and this
carries over into many other aspects of
your performance so enjoy oh and the
same approach used in this push-up
routine can also be used with many
different exercises for example I'm
currently using it to master the pseudo
planche push-up tip with fans for the
useful interesting guys let me know in
the comments if you gave it a try and
what you thought and leave a like if you
did find it useful you can check out my
ebook and training program super
functional training in the link down
below or just subscribe to this channel
for more content like this thanks a ton
for watching and I'll see you next time
bye for now